this week on world stories Hitler's
living quarters the glimpse of the past
no future Iran's Afghan refugees but
first to Istanbul president Recep tired
Erdogan calls it fighting terrorism
closing down newspapers and putting
journalists behind bars the heavy hand
of censorship in Turkey this is the
studio where voice of life used to be
broadcast from the innocent sounding
show was shut down by Turkish state
prosecutors the program's former
editor-in-chief can vividly remember the
day in early October when the troubles
began Austin's animus on that day our
satellite transmission was suddenly
stopped at about eight o'clock in the
middle of our broadcast without any
warning it was the first day of our new
talk show format the guests had just
taken their seats and the screens went
black shortly afterwards enforcement
officers came to seal the doors the
charges against cause are broadcasting
terrorist propaganda dozens of other
radio and television stations were
closed down on the same day hundreds of
employees suddenly found themselves out
on the street many now fear the daily
newspaper jamelia could also be closed
protesters have been camped outside the
newspapers headquarters in Istanbul
since 13 editorial staff were arrested
can you dig that all on Letterman I came
here because I would like to see my
grandchildren grow up in a safe and
democratic country for that to happen we
need shampoo do innocent people are
being thrown into prison every day we've
had enough and not just domestically
there have also been large protests
abroad but the government appears
unfazed someone from the European
Parliament said to me that we had
crossed a red line by arresting these
journalists we say to you my friend that
we're not interested in your red lines
people determine our red line tension
solid bottom critical journalists who
haven't yet been arrested are seeking
refuge on the internet the former
editor-in-chief at the mill yet
newspaper doggone atkin has launched a
new news site called t24 some two
million people visit the site every day
seguros I'm Vsauce together we reported
on the government raising taxes on
tobacco products for that we got a fine
of about twenty-five thousand euros
because officially it was deemed to be
illegal tobacco advertising that's
exactly the amount we need to pay rent
and salaries for three months apology
does the voice of life is no longer the
studio and offices remain locked up RF
casa is now considering if it should
work for a publication run by the
political opposition as long as they
remain open anyhow Iran is home to some
three million afghans too many says the
Islamic Republic but the EU is planning
to boost its aid to Iran in an effort to
reduce the numbers trying to reach
Europe
they've been here for over 30 years now
some 3,000 Afghan refugees live in the
bat chm Ron Kemp in the Iranian province
of camel but Engel ami is grateful to
the Iranians for their help but the
widow doesn't see much of a future in
Iran her children have to work dangerous
jobs her son broke his leg doing so I
was 10 when I got here my kids have
never seen Afghanistan we don't have the
money to travel there and the security
situation is so terrible that our
relatives have now also fletched to Iran
about 1 million Afghan refugees are
registered in Iran many of them have
lived here for decades the situation is
even more frustrating for an estimated
two million undocumented refugees here
who mostly work illegally on
construction sites but for about a year
now they've been able to send their
children to school partially in thanks
to aid organizations and the EU EU
officials believe that if conditions for
refugees in Iran improve they'll be less
likely to try to make the dangerous
journey to Europe but closer cooperation
with Iran is essential crystal steely
anita's the EU commissioner for
humanitarian aid is convinced that
refugees would benefit greatly why not
the Afghan refugees stay very close to
their home and maybe in the next time
future time when we'll see peace in
their land and to make an appropriation
process in order to return in their
homes this is the best scenario Stiliyan
EDA's knows it's a long-term and
ambitious project a slump in global oil
prices along with growing Iranian public
discontent about so many refugees in the
country he's putting local authorities
under pressure it's by a nice here in my
yard in had a motrin adding it's very
likely the EU would notice a difference
if we did not support refugees here
last year there was a wave of refugees
heading into Europe but without the
efforts of the Islamic Republic it would
have been even worse yes domina both had
an emoji LOL are ye when ye mat-su
sandwich almost gave me shudder Krishna
steely anita's announced the EU would
double funding for Iranian refugee aid
to 12.5 million euro this year but that
still isn't enough because many refugees
here continue to dream of making the
journey to Europe
Africa now and a small village in the
south of Senegal chimpanzees in the area
have long been under threat the habitat
eroded is it too late to reverse this
trend
it's laundry day indeed a fellow women
have been washing clothes in the river
for as long as they can remember
especially in the dry season when the
village Wells dry up and water is scarce
so packaging and even old clothes are
left in the forest the community wants
to change that and has declared ginda
fellow a Conservation Park Korean camera
has sensitized the village to the need
to protect the environment twice a week
the women meet for a community cleaning
action their aim zero plastic no more
plastic waste in Dean develop some 50
women joined the initiative despite
their efforts the women have yet to
reach their goal and I thought will
cause they're plastic is everywhere
that's what we are struggling against
here we want people to use textile bags
we have expressly ordered but compared
to how it was we've taken a big step
forward Liliana Pacheco ricotta is a
Spanish scientist who has been living in
Dean dear fellow for the past seven
years for searching a habitat and
behavioral patterns of the chimpanzees
in the Conservation Park she commends
the work cut in camera has been doing
every morning at six o'clock recorte de
Sens Rangers into the forest they're
looking for a pack of about 50
chimpanzees that have withdrawn because
of the baboons the Rangers crisscross
the forest to the whole day without
glimpsing a single chimpanzee
later I really do mean we wanted to do
something for the Apes but we didn't
know how the Spanish research has helped
us we talked with all the neighboring
villages explaining what this was about
people accepted it and we were able to
found a conservation park with the other
communities are on lock up the hopes are
that the chimpanzees will bring in
tourists the villagers are trying to
protect the habitat of the endangered
species as best they can but the park
will only be financially viable if the
chimpanzees remain
last report takes us to Berlin where a
private museum has created a replica of
Adolf Hitler's bunker it's not without
its critics but the curators say it's
about providing information
a replica of where the Nazi regime came
to an end the underground bunker were
idled hitler committed suicide on April
thirtieth 1945 the war he had started
still raged on the streets above once
the Soviets occupied berlin hitler's
bunker faded from history and was later
destroyed now a new exhibition is
offering insights into the fearless last
days with a replica of the dictators
living quarters if I was open for Emma
died we're trying to demystify Hitler
debunk his legend after 70 years and
present the fact what remains is an
insidious dictator shot himself in a
basement once it became clear that his
enemies had beaten him Wi-Fi in two wars
water Hitler spent two whole months
living in the shelter behind his
Chancellery in Berlin along with his
girlfriend Ava bone as seen in the
german movie downfall the dictators
entourage still lived in surreal luxury
meanwhile the German capital was being
reduced to ruins troops and civilians
followed orders to keep fighting many
losing their lives in the process the
real location of Hitler's actual bunker
is easy to miss visitors from around the
world still flock to it some with no
clear idea of what happened here it's a
fury bunker right that's all I know
Rossi paresh I find everything about
this field very very interesting about
yeah Hitler played a key role in
Berlin's history that's why I want to
see it the new exhibition called
documentation for buca opened in an air
raid shelter still standing from World
War two visitors get a glimpse of
Hitler's final days but I also find out
how ordinary people survived in
overcrowded shelters at the end of the
war a key exhibit is this model of
Hitler's bunker its designers chose not
to use Nazi symbols to avoid creating a
pilgrimage site for right-wing
extremists
but a douche pick lakini owner neo-nazis
don't want to see how Hitler shot
himself in his bunker or him me saying
neo-nazis are idiots they wouldn't enjoy
our tours at all kinds part but NO lenze
and his team did choose to use the term
fewer bulgar not to capitalize on Hitler
tourism they say but to educate people
about the horrors of the third hi
you